it's a new week and that means it's time
for new releases and even if you're
still in the wasteland you're probably
going to want to spend some time with
Star Wars battle friends you're
traveling to Endor hof and Tatooine and
you're writing speeder bikes and enjoy
rides on a TA to use you can pick which
side you want to be on whether it be
Rebel Alliance or imperial stormtrooper
you can even play as your favorite
characters like Darth Vader Luke
Skywalker Boba Fett definitely Boba Fett
and although you can't play as them you
at least get to bask in the presence
that is r2 d2 and three CP oh the games
online multiplayer mode supports up to
40 players in one match and 12
multiplayer maps there's a lot to soak
in here and forces with you on the 17th
but hey did you know there was a
Deadpool game coming out this week well
it's not actually true the game was
developed by high moon studios and
published by Activision in 2013 for last
gen consoles and PC now it's being
rereleased for ps4 and Xbox one it's as
expected you're playing as marvel's
sadistic masked antihero Deadpool in an
action beat-'em-up video game the game
wasn't like groundbreaking or anything
but if you're a fan of Deadpool and
you're like stoked for the movie coming
out well then you could pick this up as
well for 50 bucks it might be for the
hardcore Deadpool fans but nonetheless
it's here on the 18 also this week
remember when the crew came out last
year it had less than stellar reviews
but the wilderun expansion is set to fix
a lot of those problems and boasts way
better graphics but you're gonna have to
pay for it it's 40 bucks and it out on
xbox one ps4 and PC on november
seventeenth
a few other options night squad is
coming out of early access and into
full-on release on PC it's one day
players and you could probably describe
it as Ness era Bomberman meets gauntlet
hell yeah Bomberman gala moving on to
3ds Pokemon super mystery dungeon takes
you on a quest through ever-changing
dungeons as you battle alongside
legendary and mythical Pokemon to save
the world from a crisis but really I
mean who cares you're just going to
catch awesome Pokemon and that comes out
on the 20th Game of Thrones episode 6
the ice dragon comes out on the 17th but
let's move on because spoilers finally
Mario Tennis ultra smash adds some
changes to the beloved Nintendo tennis
formula characters can perform the game
signature ultra smash shocked by leaping
into the air and hitting those powerful
down strikes gameplay modes include
classic tennis mega battle knockout
challenge most importantly online
multiplayer you can throw down online
and prove once and for all that you are
the master of this court so that's all
the games coming out this week let me
know what you're interested in playing
and remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and sometimes
they change I'll see you next week
you